welcome
everybody thank you for joining us on
this installment of is
a book about the life and times and ways
of the prophet muhammad
authored by the great late scholar of
islam
we had reached in our previous session
the chapters regarding the will
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam how he would purify himself
in preparation for prayer
and we discussed in detail
how he used to
make this wudu from the beginning to the
end
we discussed the different utkar what he
would say before
and what he would say after his wudu
and now inshaallah we are going to
discuss
other things that have to do with
but are an addition to what we had
discussed previously
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
beard
was described to be very very
thick it was a thick beard
and we see the descriptions of the
companions
that his beard would fill his chest
which would fill this area of his body
likewise the companions have narrated
that during the silent prayers
they could see the prophet salallahu
recitation of the quran by the movement
of his beard
and that is those who were standing
behind him
so we understand from this that his
beard was very
and now how did he used to make wudu
and what did he do with this beard
he says regarding this
he says and he the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
at times would do what is called
tahlil to his legia to his beard
but it was not something that he did all
the time
what is it as the scholars of islam have
described to us is that he would
take a hand a wet hand
after he is finished washing his face
and his wet hand and wet fingers he
would insert
into his beard this that's it
this is what a tahlil is he would insert
it this
and that would be all this is something
that he did occasionally
it's not something that he did every
time
now the scholars of islam have discussed
the issue of
the beard for men who are making
as we know people have different levels
of thickness of their beards and length
and so there is a general principle
that the scholars of islam have picked
up on
in their research of the broad texts
of the quran this principle states
that if the beard is thick enough
that you cannot see the skin underneath
then it is enough to merely wash the
face
over that beard meaning that the water
doesn't have to reach the skin
if the skin is not visible
yet if the skin is visible the water
must reach the skin
right and so if a person has a very
thick beard
all they would do is just wash their
face and due to the fact that the beard
has covered up the skin underneath it
takes the place of that skin
in wudu now this is only for ablution
not
for bathing in bathing
the water must reach
the skin of all of the body
right but in
the beard because we see in instances
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam wipes over his turban and
instances he wipes over his socks
or his footwear and this is
one of those things that the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam would merely
wash his face
right and sometimes insert his wet
hand into the bottom of his beard and
other times he would not do so
now the ruling is is that if a person
has a light
beard let's say their beard is very
light all over
and the skin is visible the water must
reach that skin during wudu
but if the beard is thick enough that
the skin is not visible then it is
enough to merely wash a person's face
and wash over the the beard the outside
of the beard
he says
[Silence]
would scrub between his fingers during
mudu
let a person do this during
this is something that he would do but
it's not something that he would do
every time likewise the toes
right the toes it was narrated that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would scrub between his
toes
with his pinky finger right
on the left hand that you would scrub
between the toes either like
this or this with this finger
now this is not something that
is necessarily to be done every single
time
what's important is that the water
reaches
into all of these places so when a
person is washing his hands
he doesn't necessarily have to scrub
but he does have to make sure that the
water reaches
all of the parts of his hands
now this goes for the hands the face
the feet any part that he is washing
and this is an important point because
during the different months of the year
a person's skin
especially in a place where
the climate changes a lot
let's say in the bitter cold a person's
skin will
chafe and dry when a person washes over
his skin
the cracks in his skin
the water will not reach those cracks
you have to work it
into those cracks of the skin this is
something that is necessary scholars of
islam differ
with regards to scrubbing is scrubbing
part of or is it merely enough to
pour the water over the limb that is
being washed
the correct opinion is
does not entail scrubbing so
for example a person is making
and they were to put their wall their
foot under the water
and the water coming out of the faucet
or the shower head
completely covers the entirety of his
foot
or her foot along with between the
toes and everything else this is enough
a person doesn't have to actually
touch his feet to wash them however it
is better
to spread the water around with your
hand
especially if you are making wudu with a
small amount of water a small amount we
mentioned the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would often make will do with
about
16 ounces or so
in this case a person in order to
maximize the area in which he is going
to use this water
you must use his other hand to spread
the water around
and so scrubbing between the fingers
scrubbing between the toes and the way
that we have mentioned
is something that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would occasionally do
he says and as for if a person
is wearing a ring
there is a narration that when the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
because later on in his life he had
a ring that was
literally a khatum and that is that
it said on it muhammadun
this is what it said and this is
something that he would use
when he would send a delegate when he
would send a message
a written letter to anybody
it would be dipped in ink and he would
stamp
this letter and this is something that
was used at that time it's still used
i mean we see this in nota republics and
so forth
has always been used this is something
that would be used
to indicate that this is an authentic
letter that has come from whatever
king or whatever
delegate that this
letter has been coming from and so
when he started to call and spread out
his tawa
to the other farther reaches of the land
and reach out to the
places that are outside of the arab
peninsula
such as the roman empire and the
persians and so forth
he was told and advised by his
companions that kings do not
accept letters and do not accept
messages
unless they are officially stamped and
notarized
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam had this
ring designed and it said muhammad
[Arabic recitation]
and whenever he wished to stamp
something
he would dip it in ink and stamp
whatever
letter or message he was sending
and so this was originally made out of
gold
but later on gold was made
impermissible for men and remained
permissible for women
and so the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam and his companions stopped
wearing gold and jewelry
and he had one made out of silver
now how would he make this will do with
this
ring well if the ring is tight enough
obviously the water may not reach
underneath the ring and so it is
narrated in a weak narration
that he would wash his hands and when he
would wash his hands he would move the
ring around
in order to ensure that the water
reaches inside of there
and it has been authentically collected
and reported
that the prophet salallahu
would wipe over his footwear both as a
traveler
and as a resident
and the time of expiration
for wiping over the socks for a person
who is a resident
is one complete day and night
what does that mean well
a person makes will do and washes his
feet
and then after this puts on his socks
the person has 24 hours
and a complete day and night cycle where
he can
make wudu and wipe over these socks as a
resident
if he's not traveling after
this time has elapsed a person must take
off his footwear and re-wash his feet in
full wadu
again in order to reset that time limit
he says
and the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam set
the duration of time that a person may
wipe over his footwear
or her footwear during as a traveler for
three days
and nights so 72 hours
now this is something that many people
misunderstand
and that is that when it comes to the
footwear
a person does not start this
time until he makes wudu
and wipes over them what does that mean
let's give an example a person wakes up
for fajr he makes wudu
complete wudu washes his feet and then
he puts on his socks
he makes a little fajr he has
wudu but then he breaks wudu
after making salah so he has will do
from fajr
to her he makes salah with the same undo
as fajr
but then he breaks his will between
he breaks his wudu between
then when asur comes he makes wudu but
instead of washing his feet
he wipes over his feet
the 24 hours begins
once he has wiped over meaning now he
has
24 hours starting at assa
meaning at asur the following day he
cannot wipe over his footwear
to make wudu he has to take off his
socks and wash his feet at also
not at fajr and not at all in that
example
so the time period
for wiping over a person's footwear
begins at the first wiping over that
footwear
this is something important to
understand because many people would
think
that it is once a person breaks his will
that's not correct nor is it once a
person makes will do in the first place
and puts the socks on
let's give another another example
let's say a person makes wudu at fajr
puts on his footwear goes to the masjid
makes makes salah
comes around they still have the same
but now they decided they would to
put on a different pair of socks
they still have the original wudu
they take those socks off they put on
another pair of socks they make saleeta
and then they break their wadu they wipe
over their socks at asur we still have
the exact same
outcome because the person still has
his original wudu intact
from when he took the socks off from
when he put the socks on and took
them off that doesn't matter if you have
your original wudu in which you washed
your feet you could take them off and
put them on as many times as you like
but once a person breaks his wudu
and then takes off the socks now you
have to wash your feet again
now you have removed the ruling of those
socks once you have broken your wall
and taken that footwear off
likewise another question that comes up
often
is let's say a person makes wudu puts on
his footwear
let's say a person breaks his wadu makes
wudu
wipes over that footwear and then
realizes that he should probably take
his socks or shoes
off to make salah does taking off the
footwear
invalidate your wudu the correct answer
is no it does not so if a person makes
will do
let's go back to our original example
the person wakes up
it's fajr he makes wudu he puts on his
socks
he has the same uldu until he makes
salah
he breaks his wudu and then he makes
wudu and wipes over his socks
for asar he makes salah
now salat al-makhrib comes around he
goes home
he has not broken his wudu from
he goes into his house he takes off his
socks and shoes
has he broken his wudu the answer is no
a person can only break his wudu
with a very limited number of things
that a person can do
right otherwise their will is not broken
and the correct opinion is merely
removing the footwear does not break
your wudu
however the person can't put the
footwear back on and wipe
over it no the person can have that same
wudu from asur
all the way until fajr as long as he
keeps his wadu
but once that will do is broken now he
has to make full will wudu including
washing his feet again
these are issues that come up often and
these issues become more and more
relevant
the colder it gets outside and
the more adverse the conditions become
and the more of a pain it would be for a
person to remove his or her
footwear and so
this is the time period that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam has set
the resident 24 hours and the way that
we mentioned
the traveler 72
hours in the way that we mentioned
now a person may say 72 hours a person
would not shower during that time would
not we have to understand that
bathrooms showers a restroom inside of
your house
running water inside of your house a
water heater these are extreme luxuries
that were not allotted to those people
who have come before us
right we take for granted that a house
would have
a shower in it have hot water in it
would not have would have running water
in the house would have a toilet in the
house
this is something that we take for
granted now because it is so prevalent
but this is something that is very new
to humanity
before when a person needed to use the
restroom he would have to go far
off in the distance far enough to where
nobody would see him
later on people designed outhouses
and even in my time as a young boy
growing up
we had an outhouse so this is very new
things especially in other parts of the
world
and so during those times when we read
narrations of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi was
mentioning that every believer must
at least bathe once a week every friday
at least to some of us that may seem
horrendous how could a person go for
seven days without bathing well
when you live in the desert and water is
scarce
and there are no indoor restrooms and
showers and all of these luxuries
once a week is actually very progressive
and a lot during that time
the pr the author now
even
now proceeds to tell us how he would
wipe over his footwear
when he would make he says
he said and the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam when making wudu
would wipe over the tops of his
leather socks and now leather socks
i don't want you to think and to conjure
up
the image of these nice little
novelty socks that we find in the
muslim stores or the islamic stores
where it's made out of very fine
sheepskin
and it's very soft that's not what is
meant by a hoof
that is not a hoof according to the
terminology
of the scholars of islam nor the
of the prophet and his companions
rather a hoof as we mentioned is a
hard leather and it is so hard that it
maintains its shape if you were to set
it up it stays standing on its own just
a pair of boots or a pair of shoes
this is what a hoof is and the hoof
would not be worn with anything else it
is an
independent footwear right
so he would wipe over the tops of it
so if he has his feet here his hands
would be wet
he would just wipe over the tops just
that one time
right he says
wiped over cotton socks
this is something that the scholars of
islam have differed over
and it is a set of narrations that
the scholars have differed on
whether these narrations are
collectively authentic or not
ibn a major scholar of hadith
and an imam and an expert in the science
of hadith
here says to us that yes it is authentic
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam had wiped over
cotton socks now cotton socks el joe
robine
or we would say el gel robini
cotton socks this is something that you
would wear
along with footwear you would wear it
along with your nail
and so he wiped over both
and the wiping is as we just mentioned
that hands are wet he would just wipe
one time once
that's it now you see all kinds of
things
in the in the washrooms
in massage see people that wipe
all kinds of things some people they i
have even seen people that take their
hands and they wipe over the entirety of
their footwear three times each
and so they will take their foot that
has a sock on
or a shoe and they will wipe the bottom
and top and sides and everything three
times
well you might as well just wash your
feet because your socks are soaked at
that point
this defeats the entire purpose we
have to keep in mind that this is
a bed there
are two types of
rulings in islamic law
in uz
and what this means is that there are
rulings which are
designated as worship right
and then there are rulings which are
designated as
the greater good or the better thing
to do or there are clear wisdoms that we
can identify
and that when it comes to worship
we do not give the mind
much wandering space
all right i what does that mean i'll
even have
[Silence]
he said if
islam if the religion was based on
intellect if it was based on
merely what seems to be sensible now
everything in islam allah's description
is his name is al-hakim
the all-wise so we understand that any
ruling
any law any command any prohibition is
based on
that wisdom of allah
but it doesn't mean that we always know
and can identify
categorically what that wisdom is
and so the human mind has limitations
our minds have limitations and we cannot
hope to understand everything
about the rulings of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala as an individual
no scholar knows everything about islam
nor does any scholar know everything
about
the wisdom and the reasoning behind
everything that is
legislated in islam this is where iman
and faith comes in
i don't mean this to be misconstrued
that there is somehow a a
dichotomy or a spectrum
between intellect and religion that is
not correct
rather at no point does sound
intellect ever contradict
the authentic religion of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
anytime that that appears to happen
it is either a deficiency in the
intellect
or they are not understanding the ruling
of of allah and his messenger sallallahu
alaihi wasallam properly
this is very important this kind of
false dichotomy has been set up in our
time
between religion and reason
so you have religion over here which is
just kind of arbitrary and
unreasonable and there's no it's kind of
mindless and it's all based on how you
feel in faith
and then you've got the scientists over
here
where it is just pure reason and if i
can't see it if i can't smell it if i
can't test it then it doesn't exist
neither of those two are correct
islam as a whole
coincides with solid
and correct logic if a person
finds a seeming disagreement
contradiction between
reason and religion then there is a
problem with the reasoning
the logic has not been reached properly
this is important but when it comes to
things of worship
we can try to look for why it is allah
legislated this or legislated that
but at the end of the day whether we
understand it or not
we still believe it as being a command
of allah subhanahu wa
so for example when i stand for salah
and i raise my hands at the beginning
[Arabic recitation]
well why do i raise my hands what does
that signify what is that
well the scholars of islam have
speculated as to what that is
but we cannot say ultimately with any
clear
categorical authority that this is the
reason
and this is the only reason why the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
raise his hands at the beginning or
during his prayer
we can speculate as to the reasoning
behind that and that is fine
but at the end of the day it all comes
back down to
in
indeed allah does legislate what he
chooses and his choices
are based on nothing but his wisdom
and his knowledge and his mercy
subhanahu wata'ala
and his justice he does not have
any overarching
rules of the universe that he somehow
has to
abide by rather allah
described himself in knowing certain
terms as
he is the doer of whatever he chooses
and so a person is not to say well
when i wash my feet for wudu
i wash my feet therefore if i have
some kind of footwear on it would only
be appropriate that i wipe over its
entirety that is not correct
rather the way that a person wipes after
they are finished with their ears
they go back and wet their hands fresh
and they wipe over the tops of their
footwear one time
just in the way that we have mentioned
it doesn't have to be the entirety of
the top of the footwear
and so this is how he sallallahu
and it's also been narrated that the
prophet salallahu has wiped over his
which is his turban alone
and it's also been narrated that he
would wipe over the turbine and a
portion of his forehead
as well now
this is when the headwear
is something which would be a
significant annoyance to remove
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's wives
when they would make wudu they would
wipe over their hijab
their right
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
they used to wear the exact way that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
turbans were
before in the beginning stages
of his prophethood the turban would be
wrapped
okay and the tail of the turbine would
go
under the chin this is called technique
and this is how his turban would be worn
but then later on the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would wrap his turban
and the two ends of the turbine would
hang between his shoulder blades
and so this turban is not something that
you could just take off and put on like
a hat it's something that has to be
wrapped methodically
so if a person each time he wished to
make wubu
were to remove this turban and re-wrap
it you know he would spend a significant
amount of his day just wrapping
his turban up right and so
when he would make when he would reach
the point where he would wipe
over his head he would either wipe only
over the turbine
or he would wipe over the front of his
forehead and then finish
on the turbine in the way that i have
just demonstrated
this is when a person is
needing to do so if they'll cut him
it's possible that the only time he
would wipe over his
turban is when he needed to do so like
he's traveling or it's
bitterly cold outside or there is some
reason why he is not going to take his
turban off
then and only then he would wipe over it
otherwise he would take it off
and wipe over his head he says
and it is also possible that any time a
person has a
turban on or some kind of headwear that
would
be would be annoying to take
off and put back on and to wrap and
something that is lengthy
then a person can wipe over it during
mudu
whether they need to or not whether they
are
whether they are in normal conditions or
under
necessary circumstances likewise for
women
ibn al-qayim says and this is more
apparent
it seems to be that it is more likely
that the prophet alaihi wasallam wiped
over his turban
and this is something that is set for
all of the
muslims that a person may wipe over his
head where no matter what his
circumstances
are he says
he says and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would never
change the state of his feet
in whatever state his feet were in
with regards to footwear upon making
wudu
is how he would make wudu so if his feet
were bare and time for salah would come
and it's time for
he would wash his feet he wouldn't put
on something just to wipe over them
likewise the opposite if the time for
salah would come and he wished to make
wudu
if he had something on his feet he would
not take off what is on his feet to wash
over his feet this is as well incorrect
the sunnah is however you are when the
time for wudu comes
that is how you make your wudu you
neither take your footwear off to make
it more difficult
nor do you put your footwear on to make
it more
easy now does this mean that it would be
invalid if a person did so the answer is
no it would be valid
but it would not be the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam unless there was a need
to do so
then goes into the issue of tayammum
and tayammum is a very important issue
because water is so plentiful because
alhamdulillah we live in a time when
water is
abundant and we have running water and
every
building now it is something that
a lot of people maybe have gone most of
their life if not all of their life
without making to yemen a single time
and this is a great blessing from allah
but it doesn't mean that we don't learn
how to do it
it doesn't mean that we don't have that
knowledge
for the time when we need to use it and
employ it
this is something we will speak about in
our following
lecture insha allah thank you for
watching
with so